200 years ago, he was born.
He wanted to know how the whole of the natural world interconnected.
He wanted to know how continents emerged,...
...how ocean basins formed.
He wanted to know how life evolved.
150 years ago, it was published.
It's transformed the way that Western cultures have regarded the Divine in the natural world.
One man on one voyage changed the way we see ourselves.
He dared to question the need for a supernatural creator.
But what drove him to explore a new explanation for the existence of all living things...
...and why was it so controversial?
I've studied Darwin all my life...
...and behind that great, big beard, he still remains an enigma.
150 years later, we explore this enigma...
...examining the ideas of Charles Darwin in the light of today's knowledge.
Do they still have relevance?
Does his science still make sense?
We embark on a journey of understanding where we revisit the voyage that shook the world.